everybody what's going on welcome to
Street Coco day 3 is 3 this is for day 3
or 4 3 I don't know who knows thank you
for joining us once again we're super
excited because today we have Scott
Aukerman ladies and gentlemen that's
right that's right Hollywood royalty is
here sweetness my camera Scott if you
don't know comedy bang bang a two-time
Emmy winner co-creative between two
ferns and many many other things
videogame enthusiasts I would put that
first actually why we bury the lead on
that one thank you for joining us and oh
Brooklyn will says if I don't get one
hey nog man on this stream exactly now
you can turn it off and today we're
gonna be playing a couple of games but I
think we're gonna play this game neither
one of us to play before surgeon
simulator and I think we have to work
together I think we're each me to go one
arm okay I'm not sure why I have to be
the jerk-off arm oh yeah you'll be just
jerking it solid exactly and I will be I
will be I think I'm wearing the watch so
alright so this is gonna be yeah I'm not
exactly sure what does what okay I think
I want to slap him yeah hello I just
let's make sure he's asleep first before
we break him open okay exactly
hey everybody oh yeah what's up Germany
how's it going hand from Germany hey
2016 there we go right right you know so
you a very very busy guy we were talking
right before we started you're going to
Montreal next week yeah for the Montreal
Just for Laughs festival that's awesome
a comedy bang bang sky look at this try
these
there we go so I think this I think this
goes up and down okay so if you want to
touch him I think you can pull the
trigger on the left there you go there
you
[Music]
elissa uncle Chan says he's eating lunch
this is the perfect perfect one I think
we got to crack the ribs try grabbing
that hammer over there okay yeah and I
think you grabbed with these two oh
there we go oh you got it why is it
looks like like crab you might be on
like a plane one of those vomit comet
exactly hey shady fringe what's up yes
this is co-op with cocoa gaming oh my
god this is it's just drunk surge and I
think I think we dropped the hammer down
you know maybe we could use the clock
let's see if we can use the clock dude
yeah this is gonna be a real short game
this is exactly how I perform surgery by
the way exactly yeah what can I get help
us out Jay who's been in heart surgery
before help us out this game is the
worst they should put us into this
situation in the first place you don't
know anything about surgery exactly we
should experience through this we should
have first played the game on medical
school this is irresponsible gaming yes
this is terrans life isn't stopped oh I
found the heart I found the other heart
I don't need a king poppers it's like
Highlander do we get all the powers of
the other person there's a bone side of
the right I know brain food lunch like
bone zone or the rain there's a bullet
side of the right up so wait let's talk
about quickly your executive producing
two great shows bajillion dollar
properties yes and wife which is out
take my wife is out in a couple of weeks
on see so calm and explain if you could
explain you got it I got it
I'm gonna let's cut him up oh no oh oh
let me get in there you just stop the
bleeding kits these two it's bit like
these two together two together
see I'm doing cuz I'm doing this well
there we go yeah see if you can try the
beat when you get down there okay try
these two too many buttons
I missed the day of asteroids when there
was just one exactly
so be joined our property stars me out a
lot Hopkins yeah great the great pod
Hopkins the great tide great cast of
people and season 1 is so funny and it's
one of these it's like a parody show of
like house hunters and this stuff or no
that's yeah it's sort of like a million
dollar listing only dollar list like
it's it's really more like reno911.com
line Annan Ben grant they both executive
producer with those guys are cool
there's yeah and they're also in it and
yeah it's just like you know instead of
arresting people they go to houses did
you get my hammer I got the hammer I'm
going in him I'm trying to I can't get
enough velocity I think this is very
you're just dancing over there I haven't
been able to pick up a single thing it's
more interpretive dance I think if this
is how you crack a rib how is this fun
this is not fun this is what we call on
the fun and after me I figure it out
hammer time that's right
solid bullets said I love this guest I
love your wolf that's right well thank
you ah you've got so many projects
that's awesome I know I got it I want to
retire
yeah what is what is something you got
to do you co-wrote the 67th Emmy Awards
yeah
Oscar and the Oscars what is that like
what is it like what I mean what does
that process well the Emmys was a little
more fun and I had more to do because
Andy Samberg
uh he great he asked me and Neil
Campbell or head writer on comedy bang
bang to do it and so we we would have
had to and we did delay the comedy bang
bang the whole season in order to do it
ah so I said okay we can do it if only
if you hire all of our writers and those
are the only writers that make sense so
and he was you know he's a big fan of
the show he loves comedy bang bang so he
said yeah done so all of our writers we
just like paused in the middle of our
season and wrote the Emmys and it was
great because he he worked super hard
and he worked super hard yeah yeah
oh you're cutting it nice I'm just
getting in there yeah we've been trying
to get this off I figure I can make it
I'm trying to poke through the ribs and
like you know what I'm saying
but yeah he Andy works really hard he
was a great host he was there like every
single day Wow working with us you know
and a lot of times if you're doing these
things you don't know what you're gonna
get because maybe a host don't show up
you know every once in a while it
doesn't want to rehearse Oh Andy Andy
was there all but I only really wanted
to make it really great that's awesome
yeah so and you know I thought he was
awesome at it he was such a good host a
lot of people you know we kind of
expected the reviews to be like you know
they always are just mixed of like oh
this is funny this wasn't funny yeah but
across the board the reviews were all
saying like he was one of the best hosts
in recent memory so it was really really
fun Oscar's was slightly different
because I was actually taking the comedy
bang bang season she was only there part
time but it was cool working with Chris
Rock I never met him oh my god that's
hot yeah what a pro oh my god yeah yeah
he was great what's the what so how does
it who's the arbiter of like taste Lee
is there then a an Emmy panel or an
Oscars panel or is it just the host it's
the host Wow
really and as a matter of fact the Emmys
nor the Oscars don't really have much of
a say in what happens on the show as far
as the host material is concerned when
they when they hire someone they hire
them to do the show yeah you know and
Andy pretty much got to do exactly what
he wanted the entire times wow that's
awesome
yeah that's a lot of trust that's
amazing yeah it's really I mean it's a
great situation to be in because you
unlike other jobs you don't feel like
you're being sort of watched over the
entire time by the Council of Elders
hooded Oh we have a council know oh sure
sure you pray to the the night God yeah
is it time look okay that's a good
that's good and then what's the writing
process for a comedy bang bang well
that's I mean we have a really tight
group of people and you know most of
them have been working on the show since
the very beginning
or at least a lot of them have been
doing the last 60 episodes so there we
go I knocked it on nice well done but
yeah we basically we try to I think I
cut myself yeah I got him okay perfect
we basically try to write the storylines
first again we try to write the sort of
act 2 videos which are the movie
parodies and stuff like that second and
then at the very last minute people
guest on the show you know they usually
we can't book them into like a week out
or something oh wow that's crazy you
know working on Conan yeah yeah exactly
so we usually don't even write for them
until you know like maybe a week out at
the most then we prepare ourselves for
them to cancel what's happened so many
same things do the same thing with our
show yeah Nakhla morning morning up and
this is you're halfway through season
five yeah at our 100th episode
that's crazy congratulations and what
are some what are some of your favorite
moments I mean I know it's kind of like
picking between children but every
parent has a favorite child so I think
my favorite episodes over the years well
one of my favorite moments definitely
was having pee-wee Herman on the show oh
yeah he stabbed his head I don't think
nobody saw that Freddy Krueger here
pee-wee Herman you know was a big
influence on the show and I lutely
agreed to be on it and he he wrote all
new peewee bits for it sort of like that
Lederman back in the early eighties oh
my gosh do I have it now I I don't know
no no I'm still slapping away you just
work on the slapping you have to figure
out how to pick up one thing yeah that's
gonna be what I'm gonna be in charge of
trying to pick up one thing and what did
you learn from working with football he
was great he was you know he was so
professional and he was really you know
at one point we were talking about a
sketchy wanted to do where a snake was
gonna jump out of a box and bite him
know me okay he bit me and still
slapping away there's a safe word
involved and he you know we were trying
to figure out how to shoot it because it
was like him holding a box that he
pulled out and it was supposed to open
and a snake was supposed to jump out and
bite me and we were we were trying to
come up with all these solutions you
know when we read it about like CGI in
the snake yeah I'm gonna do it and he
said oh no no no and then he drew us a
picture of basically a box with a hole
in the back and a snake on a stick that
could jump out and just do that it was
the most lo-fi interesting easy solution
and we thought that can't be that's
simple yeah it's never gonna work
again we and we got on set and we did it
and it looks amazing it looks like
scarier than if you were to CGI
something's insane and you know he just
has that kind of mind where you know he
knows like old joke store tricks and
vaudeville yeah you know he has that
kind of interesting mind and a lot of
his comedy is based on that kind of
stuff you know that's also it was really
it was really cool were you at one point
he uh he was talking to me because
there's a lot of downtime when we're
working on the show you know every takes
and he was talking to me and he said
have you been to the Walgreens on sunset
and vine which had just open up it's
like no he goes it's really amazing
there's sushi there and so much he goes
you know I'm just gonna make an
announcement if he stood up to the crew
excuse me I have an important
announcement
and I mean told everyone about the
Walgreens how great it was made me go
check it out yeah I have real sushi
chefs that's crazy all in LA but yeah it
was so much fun he was dressed as a
cowboy he got to like walk off into the
sunset and it was just a really like a
dream come see me quit this game yeah
this is awful yeah that's great let's
play a little game called rock you rock
Italy this is if you've ever heard of a
game called soccer or football in the
European no football
yes football this is that but with cars
so we're gonna be reach gonna be really
we're gonna get hitting a ball hitting a
ball this is right and this will be
future bloodsport I'm sure at about five
or six years once Trump as president
that's support I'd speak of amazing
experiences you did between two ferns
with Barack Obama Barack Obama yeah it
was incredible what you wanted me for
congratulations Thanks and what was the
deal I mean there's so much he's the
president's yeah the main thing we know
about about Barack Obama that Perfect's
all right let's play oh yeah people
should join us we're gonna do yeah it's
Coco Coco so if you want to play Scott
Aukerman uh-huh that's right the guy who
just told the amazing pee-wee Herman
story that you're all changing your
pants because you ruined them enjoys his
cocoa and cocoa and will play in Utopia
Coliseum I know nothing about any of
this um and what was that so we spoke a
little bit about that this when you came
before and talked to the team cocoa
podcast but what was one thing that kind
of surprised you with working with the
president and his team all that stuff I
I was surprised
just you know how relaxed he was and how
he was sort of improvising around you
know yeah it was a lot he was a lot like
a real comedian who you know when a
comedian gets material they sort of like
like to go off script or make it sound
like themselves he wasn't you know
reading the joke Sofitel
they're just very dryly he is really
making it come to life so I didn't
expect that I expected him just to read
the stuff and we would get the footage
kind of made it his own playing around
with it he was like sort of insulting
Zach off script and it was yeah it was
really cool are there any jokes that he
kind of wanted to do that you were like
because it seems tough it's him I think
we use anything that he did that's great
yeah yeah it wasn't like cool experience
I mean it definitely was
it was strange cuz I almost was
disassociated from my body in a way of
like sure I had to I had to get the work
done and so I I didn't allow myself to
be nervous really yeah so so you know at
one point I was told he would only do it
once and then he was gonna walk out of
the room oh wow and I was like the Lord
watching it the first take going oh man
I wish we could do another take this
like not not he wasn't bad at but Zach
was kind of a little rusty and nervous
and you always I mean you always want a
safety take you always you have another
honor you always want something yeah so
so here so let's join it see I'm here
you want to join orange or blue either
going down yeah yeah so just I go up and
then hit X great all right and then this
is gas that's all I didn't just go for
the ball that's all it is
uh you so you're watching the first two
marks per second oh boy and I've been
told expressly like don't ask him for
another tag he's just gonna walk out
amazing and so I've been told he won't
talk to me directly necessarily Wow that
that he'll kind of talk to his advisers
about how win so I'm sort of prepared
for it to be like oh well we'll get what
we can get sure and you signed yourself
- yeah sure yeah this is gonna be his
process and after the first take he
turns right to me looks at me he goes
well how'd we do and so like I've been
told not to ask him for another take and
I say well to be honest mr. president I
loved it halfway through I thought you
guys really
fell into a rhythm and I would love to
be told or I would love to do another
take of the first stuff but I've been
told you don't have any time and he says
very diplomatic let's do it again
we got another take and that's the take
we ended up using was really and almost
instinctively he at the point where it
got good the previous take he turned to
me and said that's where it was right
but I was so surprised that after being
counseled by in that way that I had the
guts to actually do it that yeah that's
awesome and that's really I mean weirdly
you know like being in show business and
being around all these celebrities and
things that's kind of like almost where
that instinct takes over Isis right yeah
just like it's about the work I can't
you know yeah I I think I was more
nervous with pee-wee Herman the first
time I met Paul Reubens and I
interviewed him itself by Southwest I
think if you listen to that episode you
can hear like my nerves
sort of quaking a little bit I also was
like more nervous meeting you too
honestly because I was told like about
you too as well I was told don't joke
around with them really yeah like just
they want to be a serious interview or
they won't get the jokes or something
and then immediately bono start joking I
was very confused like what is going on
but I was told do not joke around with
them I took about half way before I was
like these guys want to joke around so
that was like way more nervous to talk
to them than the president I think
that's great I feel like a lot of times
with with big celebrities or big
important figures they're people kind of
say that just to set expectations yeah I
think that that's sort of as I found in
this job the publicist job to be like
protective of their client absolutely
yeah which is most people don't need it
I have found a couple of people who need
it but you know like I don't you know my
publicist know that I don't care in any
situation you know
I don't even leave with my life sometime
yeah but I think I think that's the part
about doing between two ferns at school
is we usually we don't allow publicists
in there and oh wow we just you know we
only want the person in the room and
that's it right and if people are
willing to drop their guard and just you
know have a fun time then it ends up
being a really cool video like Brad Pitt
oh man so great just let us ask anything
we wanted and it turned out really great
the ones that get weird or when you know
they say oh we want final cut they don't
trust the process yeah or they watch a
video and go well I want to be more
funny or you know or I want to recut
this when I get back from hey no I'm
sorry
smashmouth you don't get to recover what
happened happened but yeah and that was
a it's interesting cuz like Conan when
he went he did a Sanel I kind of said
the same thing like he didn't he didn't
bring any of his writers he just write
Wayne and Houston just did it well he's
one of the greatest writers on SNL ever
so I mean I can imagine
he doesn't need a lot of help he has
great writers here with him as well but
yeah and that's that's what you're told
when you do SNL apparently is like just
just go over and surrender yourself to
the process they make you funny in and
that's that's what a comedy bang bang
that's one thing that you know I would
say 100% of the guests have done for us
that actually show up yeah they're the
ones who just say no more I'll do
anything that you want me to do and no
one has ever asked to see the show after
we've done it before we put it out it's
just you know it's just you know you get
to see celebrities in a really
interesting light in a way that you'll
never see them ever anyplace absolutely
and and plus now you know fifth season
you guys have created such an amazing
body of work that who wouldn't who would
think that oh I could do better you
don't have funny I know you Betty
you'll be sitting there with someone in
and I never know if anyone has seen the
show or knows what they're in for
okay I mean but it is an extremely
famous show well you have to assume like
someone has showed them an episode or
something yes but you know the process
of making it is so kind of crazy and we
just like make people dive right in we
start everyone off with this improv
interview
or they don't know the questions and you
know like we had Allison Janney she's
coming up in the back town of this
season and she's after like ten minutes
she was laughing her head off and going
I feel like I'm high right now what is
happening this is just such a crazy
experience and you know like Weird Al
and I are both employed with her and
just you know it's such a strange
experience that's unlike anything you
know you do in show business absolutely
and we just had Weird Al here out last
night right yeah yeah and he just took
over about it he did it luminal uh yeah
he's bandleader now yeah which is
fantastic and how is it working new
collaborators real it's awesome I mean
you know I I was really obsessed with
him since the early dr. Demento
Tammy T in Los Angeles and you know I
heard him ever since another one writes
the bus and Yoda and so and I used to
collect his not just his lp's but his
singles Wow now they didn't have like
unique b-sides just because the artwork
on them yeah was unique so you know then
I got to know him a little bit and and
you know became friendly with him but
never really expected we would work
together and in that kind of capacity
and when Kid Cudi
decided he wasn't gonna come back for
the next season I just kind of sent him
an email like I know you don't have time
to do this yeah I have fun on the fifth
season and he wrote back immediately
saying this is my favorite show I really
want to do Wow
because it seemed it's such an amazing
fit yeah it really is and I think you
know you get to see I saw al last night
here in San Diego performing in concert
and you get to see him in a different
light almost you get to see him I mean
his his albums I think are different
than comedy bang bang and doing sketch
comedy you know I don't know he's
usually been in charge of all of his
sketch comedy you know al TV and The
Weird Al show so he really gave himself
over to the process and just Wow let us
write anything for him that's amazing
and so so you get to see him in a
different light I kind of feel
it's him you know being funny in another
way than he usually gets to be funny
which i think is really cool absolutely
for him too because I'm sure oh man if
we get kicked out of her own game only
you know what I try gonna try to join
blue who don't know yet do it that's
what happens yeah perfect I slipped
again no you got to join blue so orange
one that time yeah don't quite know what
I'm doing I'm trying to hit the ball
yeah yeah you're doing well you're doing
well um and that's amazing and it's
gotta be great for him to to be able to
grow you know he's done so much and had
such an amazing career but to be able to
now grow and eat and find a new way I
feel like he's had a point in his career
he's you know he's out of his record
contract and this is not me with any
insider no yes this is literally just me
on the outside looking in yeah I feel
like he he's probably at a point in his
career where it's like I have nothing
more to prove I have a number one way
I'm doing really well I'm an icon and
what if I were to do something kind of
cool that that I've never done before
you know it's he hasn't done a TV show
since I believe the 90s Oh The Weird Al
show and it's just and especially
something that someone else is writing
in in charge of oh my god and so it's
it's just been really really cool and
some days I was just sitting there kind
of going you know if I could talk to the
you know 15 year old me and tell him
everything's gonna be okay and I was
gonna be able to have sex I could have
talked to here now and told him that I
was gonna be having sex as a 15 year old
kid I would have been arrested yeah your
wife actually created billions of doing
other properties yeah yeah yeah it's
been awesome I mean it was her first
show and awesome you know you just never
know how someone's gonna do you know the
first time in doing a show and the show
so funny so that's really great yeah
yeah and so so now with this live tour
you you toured all around the u.s.
no to Montreal you're going to Australia
what can people expect if when they come
to see a live show yeah we just did the
North American tour we have we have a
day two tonight in San Diego and then
Montreal next week and then we're doing
Australia and maybe hopefully somewhere
else out of the country before the end
of the year but it's it's been cool
because you know you you sort of say
like oh I'm going to see a live podcast
is that is that really a thing that
people want to come to yeah and the
first couple of years when I did the
tour I sort of was like well I got to
make it worth the money so yeah I would
do like a half hour of prepared material
before okay and then I quickly found out
that people didn't care about that
really they they wanted to see the
podcast like they they they're paying to
see the pot yeah yeah and anything that
that delays them from Washington booked
nests they don't want to see so it's
actually where you were angering the
crowd before yeah exactly yeah really
kill me yeah exactly
so yeah I mean it's it's it's been
really interesting that they they just
want to see the podcast and so that's
what we do I mean for the North American
tour it was Paula Tompkins and Lauren
lapkus and then we would have special
guests and openers and we're we're all
doing Australia and they're doing
Montreal tonight we have Lauren and a
few other special guests and it's it's
it's crazy that you know we're able to
you know sell out you know ten thousand
seat theaters with people just watching
us improvise a podcast but it's really a
testament to the power of like how
popular stuff on the Internet is oh my
god well I mean the the podcast except
gets like 2 million downloads and
episode and it's 102 billion sorry -
brilliant - bajillion but you know so
you know it's like one of the top ten
comedy podcasts yeah I mean you know
some would say is more popular than the
TV show which is like crazy so no
you know but I mean that's like this
this thing is super popular right what
yeah you know video games are crazy
popular yeah and you know so it's like
these new ways of people getting to know
you I think you know that the TV
necessarily hasn't caught up with that's
true that's you know and kind of can't
deliver on I mean that's yeah that's
exactly yeah there's a there's an
intimacy to a podcast that TV will kind
of never be able yeah but that and
that's what's interesting about the live
show is people are gonna see something
that that has never been done before and
that we will never do again and that no
one else will ever get to see you know
and being able to see hit the ball ah
yes first touch being able to actually
see how we do it
is so much fun for people and you know I
mean the shows are wildly uneven I would
say yeah yeah exactly you're gonna get
to see something that no one else will
ever get to see you guys just joining us
we're you're here with comedy bang bang
Scott Aukerman and get your questions
and somebody actually asked how you are
incredibly busy how do you balance work
and family that's a joke for my show yes
it literally is the toughest thing about
I see why it's oh so deciding in
Tarrytown I knew you were awesome every
good show with Brian stack there mr.
work oh my god amazing yeah no ready for
really great Colbert he played Michael
Caine yeah that was a fun show that was
the beginning of our out-of-town show
are there any are there any guests that
you I mean I couldn't imagine but you
would like to have I mean I'd love to
have Conan he's turned us down every
single and ears been on there we go
but you know David Letterman I think was
it again oh I was on the show
I know he'll never do it but it would be
great to get him on bang bang or at
least ferns or something absolutely yeah
you've all been you know the greats
Bill Murray or worse you know we've had
so many great people on though it's kind
of like you know it's hard
[Music]
I sort of collect on comedy banking I
would sort of collect like oh I got
three out of the five kids in the hall
I'm sort of like chasing the fun I got
okay I finally got all the UCB food sort
of like that you know I mean almost like
a collector somebody actually asked how
do you know when did this is maybe a
little making the sausage but how do you
know when to drop a joke in the writers
room um is it just kind of a collective
feeling like it's really I mean those
guys are so talented I'm sort of the
last line of defense
okay like the first person come in and
we talk about where we're in episode can
go yes generally and then we'll talk
like sort of like okay it could probably
go like this this and this and I'll say
write up an outline okay and then it's
pretty much those guys are so talented
that it gets to me and it's really great
and then it's just you know kind of me
going like I don't like it going this
way let's take it this way or I like
this joke so it's pretty much my call of
if a joke stays in or not interesting
everyone I blame let me write it up you
know I'm the last person to rewrite
everything yes yeah but most of the time
I don't have to do much
yeah and it's your voice so here you
know joy oh man we're gonna have our own
game this happened before
are you in I'm spectating spectate oh
wait maybe okay did I get a boost here
no why does everyone able to matter but
I mean I'm you know what I am terrible
at this game
I just basically just drive around okay
there's a joy by car there's some
Rockets on the back oh yeah you can yeah
if you hit a circle you can do the right
and there's also I think you can jump by
hitting X but really
that's right Oh Oh somebody loved oh
yeah you wrote a couple common love that
you spider-man vs Deadpool you wrote oh
yeah that just came out a couple years
ago people here at comic-con can get it
anyway like that was that was that your
first comic book written it was not I
did I did an issue of Deadpool er I did
five pages in an issue of Deadpool with
that Brian Posehn and Jerry Douglas and
then I did a ten page story in Secret
Wars Journal and what's it like writing
because that is such a different format
than writing for TV or movie yes or
anything else because well you got to do
a panel by panel right you know what I
mean like you have to say panel one this
person does this cuz you're also kind of
the director yeah it's a lot it's a lot
like that it's a lot like directing a
film before you have the actors yeah
that's a little like telling the actors
it's like being David Fincher in a way
like you're gonna do this exactly the
way I want to do it and if you don't
you're gonna have to redraw but this
time the Spider Man Deadpool was was
actually more interesting or not more
interesting but the interesting in a
different way uh-huh because I got to do
it sort of what they call the old Marvel
style I don't know if you know anything
about comics I do but not about the old
Marvel stuff okay so nowadays when you
write a comic you write a script and you
do it panel by panel I knew you
explained every single thing that's
happening in it alan moore method where
it's like you're telling about the
history of the shoe yeah all these
things and everything that the artist
should find important to draw okay
yeah the old Marvel method was you would
write kind of a page-by-page outline and
say what happens on each page generally
let the artist draw it oh that's it just
then go back and script it afterwards
and put dialogue in so so we were
shooting the last ten episodes and they
asked me to do it and they needed it
really really quick oh well because it
was a fill-in issue and I said you know
I'd love to do it but I don't really
have time to do it the way we you know
we normally do can I do it the old
Marvel method
yeah and they said yes and this artist
Riley Brown took my you know pretty
bare-bones outline with you know a lot
of the jokes were in it but just like
spider-man speak there wasn't even one
page where it's like I honestly don't
know what to do with
it's you know have them fight and he
took it away and like the art is
beautiful and that page he came up with
a great solution for what I needed to do
that's fantastic and then I and then
basically because it came in kind of so
late I was in Hawaii actually having to
actually scripted on vacation he was
supposed to come before I left for
vacation back so I was in Hawaii
actually like writing jokes and going oh
wow this didn't turn out the way I
thought it was gonna turn out what joke
can I put on the page for this so it was
a really interesting challenge I mean in
that way it was way more collaborative
then which is sort of how we do comedy
bang bang and everything which is you
know I liked it maybe a lot more but you
have less control over the process and
like what story you want to tell
share in that way but it's cool I mean I
got to write spider-man in all three
stories that I wrote which is my is my
face I got to I got to say spider-man he
swings through the comedy bang bang said
where Al and I are are there
spider-man says that comedy bang bang is
canonically his favorite television love
like he just trying to do who gets it
there must have been you turned into an
editor who then must have said yeah and
they were they were all cool they I mean
the only look they're fans of comedy
bang bang which is the why they want of
course so major the only things I had to
change were like annoying legal take out
all the ass the swears no it wasn't even
that historic because he was said it was
basically set the story as Deadpool
finds out they're making a movie about
his life so he goes to Hollywood and he
needs spider-man to come with him
because spider-man has so many movies
about him already he needs him to sort
of guide him through the business it
makes sense so because there were some
you know a satirical of Hollywood there
were so many you know you have like
licensing issues know you have Ryan
Reynolds and you know I was trying to
put the Fantastic Four into the issue
and have them kicked out of Hollywood
and I was told I couldn't do that
you know like a bunch of like legal
things that were you know we had to put
a mustache on the Ryan Reynolds
character to make it not look like him
and so you know some of the wing stuff
but I mean joke wise they were really
supportive of everything that I wanted
to do that is unbelievable yeah there
was there's this a really good comic
book writer Dave Justice who said who
read it and said it was a wonderful
tribute to myself because there's so
many jokes yeah it's cool
somebody asked if Weird Al Yankovic was
a pie what kind of pie would it be um I
mean he would probably say why do I have
to be a pie I'll be a tie which is a
parody of a pie there we go
I don't know is that is that like an
in-joke for Weird Al that I should I
don't know I don't think so I think it's
just the internet asking about pie I
love a good strawberry rhubarb that's my
favorite yeah you know mincemeat is
always overlooked I mean he's got so
much hair yeah somebody said I'll pull
pie right every day yes good answers
good answers
uh who's got a favorite sketch of all
time of a nice sketch let's yeah let's
say not let's say now not something
you've written or yeah yeah yeah I you
know I I got in I really wanted to start
doing comedy you know I grew a love for
comedy with money Python and yes Annelle
and stuff like that but I really started
doing comedy because of mr. show yeah so
you know and this live show I saw them
do before the show came out so you know
I would have to say you know one of
those shows maybe the lie detector is
one of my favorites or maybe the
audition for mr. show - really good
sketches I think those those are very
meaningful to me those sketches and how
great was it to be able to work on and
the end their new one yeah one time done
I'm subtalar work on their new show and
it was that kind of interesting and and
a little bit poignant because
you kind of you kind of started and then
yeah we don't worry you've common those
two you know Bob and David put it out
there to the old writers and said hey
how many of you want to show up for this
and you know I know that speaking for
myself and also maybe Paula Tompkins we
we immediately said yes we'll do
anything you want
yeah and that first meeting it was Paul
and Jay Johnson and Brian Posehn and you
know Bill Odenkirk who's one of the
unsung heroes I think of the show and
and Deena wasn't there at the first
meeting and I'm forgetting Oh Eric
Hoffman and and it was just like you
know was like getting the old gang back
together yeah for for better and for
worse oh you're gonna spec to here you
want to play here you play orange but
yeah for better for worse it was a lot
you know that first day was like oh my
god I forgot how fun this is yeah and by
the end he was like oh my god I forgot
how stressful this is how much I hate
everyone it was cool I was in the again
I was in the middle of comedy bang bang
and I I was in the middle of the fourth
season we we were in between episodes 30
and 40 and so I delayed it I delayed the
season by about like three weeks right
yeah in order to be there for the
shooting and it just it was it was
really interesting because he was like
it was just like being there again those
guys are some of the funniest sketch
performers I've ever seen and I started
having like stress nightmares about them
again wow that's an everything
everything old is new again guy I'd been
my own boss for so long that I've
forgotten about like sort of answering
to someone and then specifically where I
would have dreams where I was like
arguing with Bob even though I was not
arguing with him on the show that's
crazy I would have dreams about arguing
with him and I was like oh I forgot just
like how stressful this situation is
but I mean it was it was interesting I
mean I think those guys they hadn't done
sketch comedy in ten years or so and I
mean Bob had done birthday boys right
yes but I think it was interesting just
sort of like see them get back into the
groove and I hope that they do another
season because I think four was too few
yeah absolutely
they say they want to do another season
so I hope they will and just see them
get better and better with it I think
you know they sort of ended by the end
of the process they were like kind of at
the level that they were again of where
they were at season one you know so I
would love to see them sort of like get
back to you know the groove that they
were in yeah they kind of return to four
yeah you know Bob's like such an amazing
dramatic actor now I know it what a
crazy turn right yeah and he's on better
call so I was unbelievable yeah just so
so good it's crazy to see him there was
a woman there was one sketch that he was
doing but for some reason he was eating
ribs in it the entire time he was at it
he thought it would be funny if he was
in charge of a dry cleaners and he was
eating ribs and just watching him like
his space work with these ribs and his
work with these props over the course of
like three takes doing all of these
really funny thing with these ribs I was
just like this is why he needs to be
doing sketch comedy yeah just take you
know a stack of ribs and be really funny
around all the funny lines yeah
absolutely
he's so gifted yeah he did like a fake
commercial for evils what different
evils wet peas or something and then we
have like a separate thing of outtakes
the whole thing was like outtakes but
then we're like there were so many they
made me think outtakes of yeah so much
so many pieces of the animal yeah I mean
he's he's been so supportive of me over
over the years I mean I don't know
a lot of people know but when I first
started doing comedy he would come to
see all of my shows and to help us out
you know no one knew who me and my
partner were to help us out he would
like jump up on stage before the show
and say can I introduce you guys and
like that's incredible introduce us and
do a little time to warm people up and
and anytime we asked him hey can you
film a thing for our show he would say
come by the office and we would film it
so is he really you know mentored us and
and you know and then gave me my big
break doing mr. show so it's like I
really would have done anything for
those guys that's and so I was really
happy that I got to be a part of of that
show as stressful as it was just to like
sort of celebrate the achievement of
those guys you know doing one of the
best comedy shows of all time
oh and yeah one of the most influential
for sure yeah it's crazy I remember he
was one of my earliest memories watching
stand-up he did this amazing act where
which kind of it was it was this great
act where he would he starts off by
saying I like what I it's amazing and as
he goes on he in between each joke he
keeps putting gum his mouth and you
realize he's reading Bazooka Joe jokes
off of the red it's just evolved as a
number from drew he's got like fifty
bees Alcala gum and it's one of those
things where that was kind of the first
time I realized wow Oh doing stand-up
doesn't really need to be doesn't have
to be observational it doesn't have to
be just telling strick jokes yeah it was
so smart and you know like and so
offbeat and just like really a prodigy
in that way I mean if you read about him
in the early days and you know at
Chicago and creating the Chris Farley's
Matt Foley motivational speaker
character and I think like that he
created that for himself and he was kind
of like um I think Chris will be funnier
doing this you know like yes like Bob's
an amazing performer and then for indigo
there's someone even better than me and
yeah giving it to him you know be
gracious is just and to be at that level
and be gracious so he's really like this
amazing prodigy and you forget how young
he was when he started doing all
you know cuz I always I at least because
he has so many like sort of old man
characters I always like a 40 year old
guy you know that is unbelievable I know
and now it must be kind of cool for you
to turn around and be able to influence
a younger generation comedy bang bang I
mean you know it again it's it's taken
you've been inspired Odyssey by Peabody
and mr. show and all these things but
you've really made your own brand of
humor that are inspiring other I mean I
hope enough people will have watched it
at some point it'll inspire people I
mean the one thing I do really enjoy
about the show is I get to you know I
have sort of carte blanche when it comes
to casting yeah and so not only do I
like I said get to have all of these
people who have influenced me on the
show but I get to you know give a lot of
young comedians it's sort of like their
first job maybe their first speaking
role on camera you know that's insane
and so you know we we basically anytime
anyone has a line on the show we cast
really talented people who are maybe the
future stars of comedy and kind of give
them a little money to keep there but
also just like give them a little
experience and show them what it's like
to work on camera and a lot of times I'm
I will have people from like the UCB who
have never acted on camera before
they're really great on stage and you
can tell they're nervous and sometimes
it's really cute sometimes they like
mess up their lines at the very
beginning and they're so nervous that
they've been throwing up yeah that's
like blood out of their ear and so I you
know a lot of it a lot of my job is to
kind of take pressure off of them and go
and go look I know why you were cast
your cast cuz you're really funny and
it's it's hard to do a one-line part or
whatever but you know like this is a low
pressure situation what I'll just have
fun it's a safe space because you know a
lot of times when I was like doing doing
some of my first jobs there's no one
there that you know you feel like you're
with a bunch of strangers there's a
director who is like needing you to rush
through everything and you did
like I'm messing this up I'm messing
this up and it's a very yeah and
everyone is kind of doing their jobs and
worrying about their own thing I was
really there for you no one's even there
giving you feedback sometimes unless
you're doing something wrong right it's
only this is only the switch so you can
get very much like oh no this is a
stressful situation so I just try to
make it cool of like hey let's all have
fun and you be funny in your own way and
so that's been really cool you know -
and and I've seen people that over the
five seasons I've seen people that we
have given tiny parts to kind of rise up
in the ranks of comedy and they're like
big players and it's really cool I hope
that people will be influenced by a dump
oh I think by now for sure I mean and
that's the crazy thing too is like
especially like with the internet and
all these things I mean your your reach
with like podcast and all these other
things you're doing like I see so and
all this stuff it's really a and now
that people are starting to you know
take TV and it's kind of going by the
wayside and now the internet is rising
and so people get past that stuff around
and it's it's interesting because
there's so many projects out there that
I think people kind of pick a few things
and then go very deep and then they love
it yeah it's very like niche programming
yes which is cool I mean it's it's you
can you can now just kind of go to those
people who are gonna love stuff and the
people who watch comedy bang bang love
it and it is their favorite show and no
breach they'll preach about it yeah more
people and then the people then there's
like you know the other 99% of the
population so but it's but it's you're
you're working for those people and so
that's that's why you know we don't get
a lot of notes
I don't change jokes to make them like
more universal you know I've had TV jobs
where like you'll you'll mention a band
I remember one job I had we're in ask
EPS a character mentioned a band and it
was it was a more obscure band and the
network came up and said can you change
this to Green Day Oh God and it ruined
it would
ruin the joke and to explain the joke to
them the worst and with comedy bang bang
it's like you're you're playing to the
margins you're playing you know to the
nice audience your play to the people
who love you yeah so you know we're able
to have like Andy Samberg I think had a
mock Seif Rufus reference and even he
was like so we looked him up and it was
like one of the writers that meant
something to them Wow and when I read
something like that I go I don't go oh
we got a we got a you know make this
more universal and no one's gonna get
this joke I write it or I read it and I
go oh this is hilarious
this has specificity you know I think
comedy has to have so yeah the best
comedy is is specific and you know when
I used to watch SCTV or what-have-you
I was never like I don't understand this
Sam Peckinpah reference because I'm a 13
year old and I've never seen his movie
yes thank God I just was like oh Sam
Peckinpah must be a thing that I should
check out right exactly they're like
straw dogs
yeah so I'll check out strong dogs when
I get older all I know now is it's
really funny yeah so I mean that's
that's kind of the good thing about
doing stuff for seaso or IFC is they
don't have to have these giant audiences
anymore in order to to make their money
back
totally they can appeal to these tinier
audiences who are gonna be really
passionate about the product and how did
seesaw did your relationship with C so
come about how did it all start did you
have shows that you wanted to pitch them
do they come to you you know what
they're they're a really interesting
company because a lot of the people
worked at IFC actually oh wow I didn't
know them yeah so a lot of the people
were from the development team over
there at IFC and so I have relationships
with all of them and they you know came
to me and just said hey we really want
to work on you with a show and when it
came time to pitch bajillion we went out
and pitched it's everywhere to all these
places sure and see so stepped up and
said you know we want to do two seasons
of the show we want to make sixteen
episodes instead of every other place
was saying we want to make a pilot
to make a 10 minute pilot presentation
they were all in they were all in sand
they were two seasons of the show and
angry it's it was really good because if
we would have had to do a pilot I don't
think we would have ended up making the
show because really I don't know how
white how you pilot that show we we made
the first episode and we and because we
were shooting it along with other
episodes we got to try things and figure
it out and sort of like start and stop
and once rotate stuff in and out yeah
what and because we finished the pilot
early on in the air order and then we
figured out oh we need to add more stuff
to it we were still shooting so we just
got to that's great so if we had just
been in a traditional pilot situation we
would have turned it in the way it was
and said well if we were to do it again
we could add all this stuff and then you
know so it was it's a really good
situation especially for comedy did not
pilot comedies absolutely and just like
give an order you know but it takes a
lot of blind faith on the part of the
buyer but luckily we had you know Tom
and Ben and me there agree yes let me
guarantee it and go this is gonna be
funny you'll step in and make sure that
and I was there for all of the editing
and oh great you know so it really it
was it was a great leap of faith from
them and and you know that's that's what
they kind of prefer to do is if they
like a show they'll just order it yeah
it's so they ordered six episodes to
take my wife and you know and what does
take my wife I know it's Cameron
Esposito yeah take take my wife is it's
sort of like a Louie type of show a
fictionalised show about two comedians
two real comedians Cameron Esposito and
Rhea butcher who are married in real
life and it's just kind of them being
like newish comedians who are dealing
with the fact that they their
relationship is getting serious the very
first scene of the first episode shows
them on their honeymoon and then it
flashes back to several months earlier
when they just had kind of started
living together and started getting
serious about each other and so yeah and
then it just kind of deals with like
everything that they have to deal with
in comedy you know be it's you know kind
of sexist club owners or you know
opening for a bigger comedian and and
bombing and so it's a really interesting
show and those those guys have a really
unique voice and I think it's like a
type of show that isn't on TV or
anywhere right now where it really just
deals with the realities of two women
who are in love and about to get married
you know which you don't really see on
TV all them know yeah but hopefully
we'll see more okay oh yeah yeah well
thank you Scott Aukerman everybody this
is great yeah we're doing all the
properties and take my wife or both a
let's see so don't wait to see no
tomorrow comes out in a few weeks
yeah you know August 14th Aaron oh yeah
Julian of my properties you can get
right now and see so calm of course
comedy bang bang returns to IFC in
October and if you're in Australia
ticket techcom a you get your tickets
the comedy bang bang live tour and if
you're done San Diego see how do this
guy he's gonna be ready it's gonna be
great yes absolutely so we will see you
right back here tomorrow at 11:00 for
another stream Coco thank you guys
[Music]
you